Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to Ben from
Los Angeles?
Ben, you're on the air.
Speaker 2: Hello, David.
Hello, First-Time Caller.
Speaker 1: How are you?
I'm doing well.
Speaker 6: That's awesome.
But a question about and putting in,
Speaker 1: so I've got to ask you to either
or both turn off your Discord notifications
and don't use push to talk because every 10
seconds we're hearing a discord bling and
the I get 20 emails every time it happens.
So please, please, please see if you can do
that.
Speaker 2: Where did you go?
I'm sorry.
Where where would
Speaker 1: you do that?
So if you go into settings under notifications,
turn them all off and then under audio video
settings, turn off, push to talk.
Beautiful.
Please proceed, governor.
Speaker 6: OK, so Biden just sent in 3000
troops into Poland and around the Ukraine
area.
I'm just wondering if you think that's going
to escalate any further
Speaker 1: at this at this point, it's anyone's
guess.
Indeed, the United States is sending 3000
troops to Eastern Europe in the forthcoming
days Poland and Romania.
There were already 8500 U.S. troops on alert
at the end of January.
I don't think any prediction.
I mean, listen, anyone can predict this will
escalate or this will not escalate.
I don't think we know because I think it fundamentally
comes down to what Putin is actually planning.
And I don't pretend to know what Putin is
actually planning.
Speaker 2: OK.
Thank you for that.
What do you think is going to happen?
Speaker 6: I do have one one less different
question.
So Pfizer last week said that they are testing
and omicron variants of the vaccine.
Yes.
I'm wondering is as we progress into twenty
twenty two and twenty twenty three?
Well, what it means to be fully vaccinated
change based on that.
So I know some colleges and some small states
and some events do require you to get boosted.
I'm wondering if over time we will, though
basically the premise of being fully vaccinated
will require like four shots.
Speaker 1: I think much like with other things,
it'll just it'll be.
Are you up to date on your shots?
It'll be it'll be less about the number of
doses it'll just be.
Are you up to date?
So, you know, as as COVID continues to evolve,
it would make sense that, for example, two
years from now, the vaccine that would be
considered up to date is going to be different
than the one based on the live virus.
That's the vaccine that's been around now
for more than a year.
So, you know, I think it will.
Just as as we get beyond the pandemic phase
into the endemic phase and vaccines like the
flu shot will be modified, it's sort of like
if I say yes, I got the flu shot five years
ago, you would say, Well, you're not up to
date because that was for the strains.
Then we have a we have an up to date flu shot.
I think it'll just change to that rather than
a number of doses.
Speaker 6: Do you think I like there's people
who don't get flu shots, like every year you
think I'm sure the same is going to happen
with the COVID?
Absolutely.
Speaker 2: COVID vaccines, no doubt.
Speaker 6: But do you think like states and
different places will care about how up-to-date
you are as we as we move into the endemic
phase?
Speaker 1: That will depend on whether it
becomes significantly less severe or not,
and I think different states will have a different
perspective.
But if it continues to be severe, then there
will be states that will continue to insist
on vaccine requirements if it really does
become milder and becomes like the flu or
more mild than I think it will be handled
like the flu vaccine, which will be much less
strict.
But I think we just we're just not going to
know for a while.
Speaker 2: I see.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: Thank you so much, David.
All right, thank you.
There's Ben from Los Angeles that's going
to do it for today.
I'm so glad I was able to speak to so many
of you.
We will take calls again and we'll take a
quick break and be right back.